hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we are going to be going over all
of the deaths of importance from
throughout the entirety of demon slayer
though i do want to say that this will
only be including the characters that
have died during the current time period
and not during the past as well there
are literally hundreds of people who
died during the past so with all of that
said if you are near and here and want
to watch similar explained videos just
like this but for a variety of different
series then make sure you hit that
subscribe button and also be sure to
leave a like on the video but anyway
enough of that let's get into all of the
deaths that have happened throughout
this enthralling and utterly insane
story that is demon slayer
so sadly the first deaths of this story
just happened to be no other than almost
the entire bloodline of the kamado
family
sadly while tanjuro was out in town the
progenator of demons muzan kabitsuji had
managed to actually track down the
kamado family household and had tried to
use a small amount of his blood to turn
him all into demons after thinking that
he had killed them all he stated so they
die from an ejection of this much blood
i cannot easily make a demon who can
conquer the sun
obviously not actually realizing that he
hadn't actually killed nezuko who later
went on to conquer the sun or that
tanjiru wasn't even home sadly though he
did take the lives of kai takiyo hanako
shiguru and rokuta kamado making that
technically the five first deaths that
happened throughout the beginning of the
final selection arc the first demon that
tanjudo himself killed with the help of
a recently transformed niziko doesn't
have a specific name but goes by temple
daemon this is because the demon had
been attacking travellers who took
shelter and a small temple heart on the
pathway that led to saganji's place
during an intense fight tanjuro and
niziko managed to take the upper hand by
pushing the body of the demon off a
cliff leaving the head nizoko had
literally kicked off alone as tanjiru
prepares a knife to finish off the
demon's head he struggles to come to
terms with taking another life until a
man and a tengu mask appears and tells
tanjido that he cannot finish a demon
off using a simple knife still not
completely understanding this tantra
believes crushing the demon's head with
a rock will suffice but he cannot bring
himself to brutally end the creature
instead the demon curses at tanchiro
until his sun rises and he begins
disintegrating into ash the next and
final death that happens throughout the
final selection arc is one that truly
for the first time pushed tangido to his
physical limits this being the hand
demon who was a demon who was previously
captured by a young tsukanji to be the
final obstacle in the test the hand
demon later killed 13 of sukhonji's
apprentices because of a grudge that he
held against the retired slayer this
included sabito and makomo as well as at
least 50 other would-be demon slayers in
the final moments of the battle the
desperate hand demon tried solidifying
their defenses around his neck to
prevent death but tangido uses the water
breathing first form water surface slash
to decapitate the demon who is left in
complete shock and horror the attack
completely severs the multiple limbed
foe's head who begins panicking over his
encroaching death assuming that tanjuna
would look at him with disgust he is
instead shocked to see his eyes filled
with sorrow the demon then extends his
arm out to his opponent who respectfully
clutches it as the demon crumbles away
into nothing moving forward to the next
fatality of the series we dive into
tangible's first mission that him along
with a hypnotized neziko took part in
however before the main battle of the
ark takes place the human sokoto is seen
walking together with her fiance kazumi
when she suddenly gets sucked through
the ground by the swamp demon who
quickly kills and devours her adding her
hairpin to his collection funnily enough
the next death just happens to be the
swampy fall of a demon who thought he
could stand up to a main character so
this demon does actually have three
individual forms based off its horns
placement in tangible's first fight
against a three-horned and two-horned
demon a swamp portal opens beneath them
as a distraction while the two-horned
demon went after the girls tanger asked
niziko to continue protecting kazumi
while he dove underground the two demons
inside the swamp believed that tanju
would be struggling to move or breathe
and that he is a fool for diving in they
tried swimming at him at high speed but
the demons darts away at a sharp angle
just as tanjuro is about to
counter-attack the demons try and rush
him again but tanjudo can smell the
opening he uses a technique that can be
unleashed with an unstable footing a
slicing vortex called the water
breathing sixth form whirlpool the
attack completely slashes apart both the
demon's bodies killing them instantly
after this happens the last remaining
swamp demon falls over and realises its
other selves have been killed they demon
tries to defend its actions but after
tanturo shows up tangero presses his
blade close to the demon and forces him
back against a fence he demands to know
all the information the demon has on
muzan however hearing this he cowers and
trembles claiming that he cannot say
anything the center of fear is so strong
that the demon acts out of panic growing
his arms back and lashing out at tangido
forcing him to cut off his head finally
ending the demon as he disintegrates
now we move more into the story and head
to asakusa tokyo for tanjuro in his
second mission with the demon slayer
corps after spotting tanjiro muzan who
is outraged by the appearance of a demon
slayer wearing hanafuda earrings
summoned two of his followers yahaba and
susamaru to hunt him down yahaba used
his blood demon art to track his
movements and found out that there were
actually two more people traveling with
him while susamaru is enjoying hanbul
yahaba notices the demon slayer is
actually accompanied by three demons
yahaba takes a supporting role in the
assault hiding up in a tree away from
the action he uses the kotetsu arrows to
guide the tamari ball tearing up the
house and even managing to take off the
head of the young demon boy yushiro who
manages to regenerate and survive though
tanjiro takes on yohaba alone while the
others fight susamaru he smells an
opening thread on the arrow demon but it
snaps as soon as yohaba activates his
ability yahaba forces tanjido on the
defensive with his arrows and wraps one
around him however tanjiru flips out of
the way yahaba believes that he has
control of the battle and calls the
demon slayer a monkey for his acrobatics
the arrow demon tries to force tanjuro
away by activating his arrows but only
manages to make his sword extremely
heavy even so tanjuno manages to slash
the blade and decapitates yahaba with
the water-breathing second form proved a
lateral water wheel
over with niziko in her battle with an
annoyed susamaru they kicked the tamari
ball back and forth at incredible speeds
when izuko proves that she is growing in
strength by the second impressed
suzumaro decides to go all out against
neziko but tamiya interrupts asking
suzamaru about muzan enraged she tries
to defend her master's honor but
accidentally says his name out loud her
brain function was inhabited by tamiya's
blood art which was secretly cast across
the area forcing susamaru to tell the
truth she runs away and begs for her
forgiveness from her lord however having
evoked his name out loud muzan's curse
takes a hold of susamaru and three
demonic arms spawned from her body the
arms crushed susamari's body completely
leaving only her eye and a pool of blood
the sun rises later and the remains of
her is completely disintegrated making
our way further into the story to the
drum or mansion arc where we find
ourselves finally meeting the lifelong
companions and the best friends of
tanjuro firstly the wimpy creep zenetsu
agutsuma and secondly the lord of the
mountains and beast breathing genius
inosuke hashibera sticking with the
weird demon names during the battle
inside of the drum mansion zenitsu tells
soichi to refrain from making any loud
noises to avoid attracting any demons
sadly though the creepy tongue demon
shows up behind the duo zenith
desperately tells the demon to stay back
as they try to escape it as a demon
chases the duo into a room he sees a now
sleeping zinitsu moving into his stance
for their thunder breathing zanetsu gets
ready to decapitate the tongue demon and
without hesitation he uses the thunder
breathing first form thunderclap and
flash landing a direct slice through the
demon's neck causing his head to fall to
the ground and begin disintegrating at
the same time the horn demon ambushes in
oscar luckily though the slayer hastily
retreats leaping away
slowly the demon rounds the corner and
threatens to devour inosuke who
excitedly attacks and immediately
removes both of its arms before it can
finish its sentence in osuke then be
heads the demon with his beast breathing
third fang devour elsewhere in the
mansion tangelo continues his battle
against the former lowering six kyogai
at first tangero struggles due to the
injuries he sustained in the previous
battle in asakusa after regaining his
spirit tangible is able to adapt to the
changes by changing the form of his own
water techniques he also respects the
writings of kyogai trying not to trample
them while fighting even going on to
compliment the demon's own blood demon
art before he finally finished his
technique and severed the demon's head
kyoukai ended up dying in peace knowing
his talents were actually acknowledged
by someone leaving the drum mansion we
actually start heading uphill towards
the one and only natagumo mountain arc
which holds the beloved and beautiful
episode 19 from the anime so i'm going
to start skipping over some of the more
vast deaths that happened throughout
this story here as well as well because
a lot of deaths just seem to happen like
literally tons of unnamed demon slaves
that put their lives on the line for the
sake of mankind died during like battles
throughout these arcs so during the
first battle that takes place on the
mountain both
any nosql gets into a battle against the
so-called mother spider demon after a
hated battle with a mother inosuke
throws tanchito up into the sky towards
her from above trying to figure out her
next move in order to survive she
realizes that if she simply dies then
she will finally be at peace and no
longer have to suffer the wrath and
ridicule of her fake family witnessing
the mother spider demon accept her death
tangier changes the grip on his maturing
blade and uses the water breathing fifth
form blessed reign after the drought on
the demon beheading her mercifully where
she peacefully disintegrates afterwards
elsewhere on the mountain the sun spider
demon continued his assault against
zenitsu with yet another spewing of
venom he ordered his many spiders to
invent him the demon slayer which was
dodged but he noted that the
over-extension was causing his opponent
to vomit blood which prompted him to
label zinitsu as useless however zenitsu
prepared to resume his attack while the
demon retreated back into his house
letting loose another spray of venom but
then it's his enhanced thunderclap and
flash technique cut through him severing
his neck leaving the demon in an utter
disbelief that zenetsu had actually
defeated him over with inyosuke and his
battle against the father spider demon
inosuka attempts to sever the spider
demon's neck with his beast breathing
third fang devour only for his blades to
shatter upon contact immediately the
demon counter attacks sidney ninosuke
hurling into a tree and then picks up
the slayer by his throat
while reading another punch the father
demon repeats an earlier demand only to
be stabbed in the throat by a resilient
inyosuke unfazed the demon tightens his
grip on the youth's throat but he has
his forearm severed once more this time
by the arrival of geyu tomioka howlin
and payne the father demon immediately
regrows his arm charging at eu however
his offense and existence are soon
erased as guillu strikes him with a
water-breathing fourth form striking
tide severing his neck and cutting him
into multiple pieces
while giulio is eliminating the father
tangelo continues his battle against the
first major threat of the series one of
the six lower ranked kazuki more
specifically the lowest of the six rui
after an insanely tough fought fight in
which both tanjido and niziko unleash
new abilities tanjuro with his broken
blade manages to use the effects of
nezuko's new blood demon art to slice
through and decapitate the lowering
demon however as they fall to the ground
in exhaustion after thinking that they
had defeated the threat he realizes that
rui wasn't giving off the ash-like smell
that demons usually would rui then
reveals how he quickly cuts his own head
with his threads before tangero could
rory reattaches his head and just as
tangier was about to be cut into pieces
he is also saved by the water hashera
giyutomioka
infuriated that one more demon slayer
had shown up robbie prepares his most
powerful attack blood demon art cutting
thread rotation but in retaliation geru
uses the total concentration water
breathing 11th form dead calm to block
it nullifying the attack
rui is shocked that geu just nullified
his most powerful attack seemingly
without even trying he tries to attack
geary with more threads but before he
could do so roy's head is decapitated
with one simple slash the final battle
and death of the mountain arc takes
place between shinobu and the naughty
daughter of the spider demon shinobu
being the insector shera quickly
bypasses the demon and attacks her
simultaneously landing her own insect
breathing butterfly dance caprice attack
on the demon shinobi laments on the
demon's poor choice turning and
subsequently watching as the creature
collapses shinobu tells the creature not
to let her guard down just because she
cannot cut the demon's head off she
explains that she utilizes poison as a
weapon instead shinobu then introduces
herself as the insect teshira of the
demon demonstr as all of this happens
though their daughter daemon at first
thinks that shinobi's butterfly dance
caprice did not behead her however she
soon starts bleeding from several spots
on her forehead her chest her mouth and
her arms by the time shinobu fully
introduces herself their daughter demon
is effectively lying dead on the floor
her body twisted in agony with several
wounds she later disintegrates after the
sun rises
moving further into the story we
literally come across the culling of the
rest of these pathetic lore ranked
demons this takes place throughout the
rehabilitation arc the first of the
lower ranks they bought the dust here
was the new lower rank six kamunui while
muzan lectured them about how it had
been hundreds of years since the upper
ranks were last replaced yet the lower
ranks seem to constantly near replacing
kama nui thinks to himself that he can't
just tell them there not realizing that
muzan is actually capable of reading the
minds of those here share blood with
muzan angrily asks kamanui why they
couldn't be told there he then expands
and extends his arm into a tentacle to
grab the lorraine by his neck a
terrified kamanui attempts to apologize
but is promptly eaten by muzan killing
him with all of the confusion going down
between the lower ranks moves in again
repeats aloud their thoughts and a
terrified lorraine iv mukago exclaims
that what she thought isn't true muzan
asks her if she is denying what he was
saying and as mukago begins to apologize
and cry another blow of muzan's
tentacles crush her into the ground
killing her
shocked by this like a rabba the lower
rank 3 immediately assumes the worst and
decides it would be a wiser choice to
flee then stay if he wanted to keep his
life he dashes out of the infinity
castle at a high speed and emu thinks to
himself that that was a stupid move to
makes since muzan will kill him either
way the conclusion turns out to be
correct as wakaraba's head is swiftly
chopped off so fast that it leaves him
wondering what exactly had gone down in
his final moments as one of the two
lower ranks left alive rokuro panics
exclaiming that he can definitely still
be useful to muzan if he just defers his
death for a little while longer musamine
asks for specifics like exactly how long
lower two was asking for rokuro explains
that if he just had more of muzan's
blood then he can adapt it and
definitely become a stronger fighter
muzan angrily tosses wakaraba's head
down next to inmu and rakuro asking the
loran 2 why he should be given more
blood based upon his order and saying
that he should know where he stands
rakuru tries to protest but muzan
silences him and says that since he had
attempted to instruct his leader rokuro
deserved to die
he then killed him this left enmu as the
only remaining loren kazuki
however the next death we stick with
enmu and continue on our story into the
mugen train arc of demon slayer during
the battle on the train enemy manages to
initiate his plan to fuse into the train
and subsequently turn into some sort of
moving organism
after both tanchiro andy norske managed
to overcome enemies blood demon art the
whispers of forced unconscious hypnosis
inosuke falls towards the engine of the
train realising that that is the area
that they need to attack and with the
momentum of the fall along with its
swordsmanship inosuke uses the beast
breathing for fang slice and dice to cut
away the flesh that protects the neck
bone for tanjuro with inmo's neck
exposed tangier pleased to his father to
help him defeat the lower rank and with
that he transitions between the water
breathing and the hinokami kagada
he uses the hinukabi kagura clear blue
sky severing inmu's head truly killing
him
after the death of inmu a moment of pure
peace happens before a complete storm
washes through and reminds us all of
what the true power of someone who has
pushed themselves to the utmost limit is
sadly in one of the most hype and
literally nail biting fights between the
upper rank 3 akaza and the flame hashira
kiyojuro ringoku we say goodbye to one
of the pillars that literally holds the
entire demon slayer core together during
the heated battle the two clash one
final time with kia duro using his flame
breathing ninth form purgatory against
the kaza's destructive death
annihilation type however when the dust
disperses it reveals that akasa had
managed to punch his arm through kia
duro's stomach as kyodra coughs up
spurts of blood he summons the last of
his strength to swing his sword into a
caster's neck keojiro lets out a shout
as he drives his sword deeper in and the
kaza tries to hit him where they punch
to the face but the hashera grabs his
wrist and stops the attack before it
reaches him akasa begins panicking after
seeing the sun's starting to rise and
tries to free himself from kyoto's hold
but the hashera holds on tightly to his
wrist not letting him escape with a loud
shout of effort akaze tries to again
pull himself away from kia jiro but he
again fails as kyoto's blade moves in
deeper and deeper tangero yells to
winosuke to move again for kia duro's
sake and just as the ball-headed demon
slayer readies his beast breathing first
fang pierce akasa manages to pull
himself away from reading goku leaving
kyojiro to fall onto his knees defeated
sadly the flemishera passed away not
much longer after this moment leaving
tanjuro with words that he held onto for
the rest of the entire story
keep your heart burning
after the moog and train incident
tanjuro and the other young demon
slayers healed up and then began
training at the butterfly mansion before
subsequently joining tengan uzui the
sound hashera in an attempt to find and
rescue his three wives who had
disappeared in an extremely flashy
district known as the one and only
entertainment district so two days
before the demon slayers had started
their battle against the demons inside
of the entertainment district omitsu who
was the manager of the ikea goku house
and typical manager fashion had killed
out daki or as she knew her whatabahime
on her attitude and her behaviour to the
other people of the house after a short
but hated conversation between the two
daki reveals her demonic form to omitsu
and carries her up into the night sky
before letting her go seeing her falling
to her death where others would find her
on the ground below
when it comes to the main threats of
this ark after an extremely long fort
fight one in which everyone there
manages to show an impressive amount of
growth zenitsu was stuck fighting
against his sister demon daki while at
the exact same time botenkin and tanjiru
are fighting against the disgusting
guataro daki can be seen resisting
zenitsu's attempt to decapitate her she
attempts to use the obi to kill zinitsu
at close range but inosuke unexpectedly
rushes up revealing that he earlier had
protected his heart from being stabbed
by rearranging his organs before
proceeding to assist initsu and
decapitating the boys let out a
roar as they muster out their strength
to slice through the demon's neck at
almost an exact same time tangelo brings
his blade down on the upper rank gutaru
immediately retaliates by stabbing
tajiro in the jaw and wardly mocking him
and continuing to belittle him tajiro
though focuses all of his strength in
his body into his sword unknowingly
activating his demon slayer mark as he
screams out though not seemingly worried
at first guaranto was then left
horrified and panicking as he saw his
sister sharing the same fate as him
after the long battle zenitsu andinosuke
managed to decapitate up on the
rooftop while tanjido can be seen
decapitating guataro simultaneously on
the ground because the trio managed to
slice both heads at the exact same time
this resulted in the death of the upper
rank 6 gutado and his sister demon
after the end of the entertainment
district arc tanjota travels to the
swordsman village to replace his sword
because his swordsmith haganezuka is
tired of actually repairing it however
tanjiro along with genya shinozugawa
nezuko the mr shira muchiro tokito and
finally the love hashira mitsuri kanroji
are pitted up against the upper rank 5
gyoko and the extremely emotional upper
rank 4 hantengu
during the battle between the mr shira
and the upper rank 5 they continuously
yell and start insulting each other with
yoko growing furious after muchero had
insulted his parts
with this he uses his blood demon art 10
000 gliding slime fish but muchuro
easily counters it with his missed
breathing sixth form lunar dispersing
mist and then follows it up with his
missed breathing third form scattering
missed splash slicing the head of the
demon's mould as he escapes into a tree
as well
when kyoko tries to show off his new
form mature's indifferent attitude
towards it enrages him and he engages in
another attack which mature dodges
easily and then smiles commenting on the
uselessness of his offense another
scuffle between the two in shoes with
gyoku using his blood demon art killer
fish scales and mature responding with
the form he personally developed his own
misbreathing seventh form obscuring
clouds when kyoko becomes confused and
tries to find him in a sea of mist
mature effortlessly decapitates him
leaving him to disintegrate on the
ground
elsewhere at a similar time in the
village tanjuro nezuko and genya are
desperately trying to chase down what
they suspect to be the real hansengu
while ken roji also does her best to
hold off his emotion demons which have
ended up forming into one more powerful
hatred demon which to put it extremely
simply for those who haven't seen my
other videos are different parts of
hantengu's emotions that take different
forms of the demon so that the real
hansengu or the cowardice version of
himself can stay hidden and out of the
battle to ever prevent dying
in the end though tangero manages to
behead him using the hanokami kagura
flame dance however as per usual
continuing with the cowardly behaviour
of hantengu the hair tanjudo just cut
was not the real hantingu proven as the
headless body of antengu continues to
run away the sun is about to rise though
and tangier is put in an extremely
difficult predicament whether to chase
after the upper rank 4 or save his
sister nezuko from the sunlight but in
the end he finally decides to continue
in his pursuit of the demon or should i
say that nezuko's sacrifice and kicking
him over towards the demon wouldn't be
for nothing tangible eventually locates
hantengu's real body inside of the
headless hantengu's heart ultimately the
upper rank 4 finally dies after being
slashed by tanjiro cutting the little
demon's neck inside of the heart by the
way if you want to know exactly what
happened with niziko after this moment
then make sure to check out my video on
the entire swordsmith village arc
explained and uh obviously you know
that'll cover all of season three of
demon slayer as well so if you're
interested go and check that out because
it'll keep you up to date with what's
about to be animated but anyway moving
on now we skip quite a bit further into
the story here as for one entire arc
tantido and the crew along with every
single demon slayer corps member that
still remained and were able to fight at
this point in the story were trained by
the various sashiras in an attempt to
get as strong as possible for the
upcoming battle against muzan and the
remaining abu kazuki demons after the
training arc comes to an end and the
infinity castle arc starts kakaya
ubiashiki and his family who continue to
live unguarded for over 1 000 years are
finally confronted by the one and only
muzan kabatsu-ji
during the conversation that followed
the demon lord as disturbed by kagaya
and his time on the mountain he spent
with him instead he wished he was back
and his fortress working on something
else he internally comments on the ubia
sheiki's weirdness erning kirk eyes aya
he tells muzan he himself graduated at
the top of his class and as the head of
missions against the 12 kazuki is
responsible for 300 deaths of young
demon slayers kagaya also warns muzan
that the hashera will be arriving soon
and that he will be engulfed in a storm
that will kill him directly threatening
muzan and angering him suddenly and
unexpectedly the mountainside is
destroyed in a massive explosion wiping
out kagaya a main their two daughters
present and completely destroying
muzan's body
muzan curses kagaya for sacrificing
himself as a decoy as he never thought
he was willing to kill himself along
with his family
sadly though with more of demon slayers
most brutal and horrific deaths shinobu
kocho comes face to face with a
psychopathic megalomaniac the upper rank
2 doma now at the point in the battle of
hedging her bet on injecting a large
dose to kill him by using a sick stab
attack shinobu strikes him using her
insect breathing dance of the butterfly
compound eye hexagon and successfully
hits him however as she attacks him he
simultaneously attacks her cutting both
her collarbone and ribs and puncturing
one of her lungs
finally nehu wits in and almost losing
any hope of victory shinobu attempts to
draw strength from playing her old
sister's words of encouragement in her
head shinobu then prepares the strike at
dome again and uses her insect breathing
dance of the centipede hundred-legged
zigzag to confuse him she strikes doma
directly through the neck impaling him
and sending him flying towards the
ceiling exhausted and wounded shinobu is
triumphant upon seeing doma being
poisoned and seemingly dying from her
attack however doma recovers almost
instantly by which shinobu is further
enraged now exhausted though and fatally
injured and dangerously near death
shinobu is caught by doma he embraces
her in a bear hug and begins mocking her
and calling her entire attempt to defeat
him a waste of effort assuring her she
will live peacefully as a part of him
and mocking her for her last words she
spitefully curses him as he begins to
absorb and kill her during another
battle that takes place inside of
nakeme's infinity castle zinetsu finds
his former comrade kaigaku who had
decided to become one of muzan's demons
after he came face to face with the
upper ranked one kokushibo zenitsu
explains to kagaku that their former
master jiguro kuwajima had committed
seppaku upon learning that he defected
to gain the powers of a demon his death
proving to be slow and agonizing since
no one was there to finish him off in
the correct way leaving him to bleed out
for hours alone
as the two continued to fight after
zenitsu had told him about jigoro's
death kagaku uses the thunder-breathing
third form thunder swarm he says that
those who judge him correctly and accept
him for who he is are correct and those
who don't accept him are wrong
kagaku then uses their thunder breathing
fifth form hate lightning and taunt
zenitsu praising his own blood demon
enhanced forms he explains that once his
thunder breathing forms slash zenitsu's
body his skin and flesh would burn and
crack apart kaikaku then continues his
attack and uses the thunder breathing
sixth form rumble and flash
while falling zenitsu reflects on its
relationship with kaigaku in the past
and he thinks how he and kaigaku could
not get along
while falling he jumps onto a wall and
uses his own breathing form he
specifically made so that he could fight
alongside kaigaku the thunder breathing
seventh form honokazuchi nokami
instantly kaigaku was beheaded and while
falling he still curses at zenitsu
however zenitsu was rescued by yushiro
and yushiro mocks kaigaku telling him
that it is pathetic to die alone
line alone at the bottom of the infinity
castle kagaku dies miserably and zenitsu
is saved by his friends
elsewhere throughout the expanse of
infinity castle geyu tanjuro and ikaza
are battling fiercely trading blows with
each other the water heshira had used up
all of his forms during the earlier
parts of the battle and the kazan
proclaims that it will be the end of the
hashera even still he was still amazed
at how long he had fought for as giu is
about to attack the demons first akasa
breaks geru's sword by using his
prolific bell splitter technique then
attempts to punch through him but all of
a sudden his arm was severed by tanjiro
who had managed to enter the transparent
world the demon notes the changes in
tangero and tries to kill the young
slayer but geyu took the moment to
attack him however akaze uses his
strongest technique technique
development final form blue silver
chaotic afterglow few tries to reduce it
with his water breathing 11th form dead
calm but the attacks were too random and
too powerful to completely cancel out
and he gets hit by many shock waves
despite managing to dodge several blows
meanwhile tanjido is able to see
everything move slowly in the
transparent world
akaza is unable to notice that tangier
was behind him and gaiu hopes that he
goes for the neck in that instant
however tangible calls out the demon and
azakaza turns to the strike tangero
dodges akasa realizes that he could not
detect his fighting spirit via the
compass and because of this tanjuro
manages to slip in and decapitate kaza
with the hanukamikage setting sun
transformation
akasa was initially bewildered wondering
how tangido did not have any fighting
spirits he acknowledged that tangero
surpassed his speed and comes to a
realization that his domain of supremacy
is nothing compared to the transparent
world and a selfless state
he attempts to reattach his head back
but giu throws his broken sword passing
the head and separating it from the body
after the head falls it begins to
disintegrate however his body continues
to fight using his technique development
destructive death compass needle again
which causes his head portion to begin
regenerating tangero dodges his swing
but is thrown aside by the demon's kirk
he tried to get up and fight but they
stress and exhaustion from the battle
caused them to pass out
here protects tangero though with the
water breathing fourth form striking
tide slicing the headless body in
various regions but again the demon
regenerates faster
the two begin trading blows although
geru is badly hurt he still focuses on
protecting tangido which gives akasa a
random vague memory of kaizo and as he
advances he is stopped by the teary-eyed
spirit of his human self's deceased
fiancee koyuki telling him to just stop
already
akaza or herkuji as a human
disintegrates not too long after this
as shinobu was being absorbed by doma
her protege kano had entered the room
and actually had witnessed her death
taking place after an intense battle
alone between the other two inosuke had
managed to crash into the room and
instantly began helping kano and trying
to defeat the man who in the past and
even now had killed anyone of major
importance in both of the young slayers
lives after doma got the news that akasa
had been defeated he almost instantly
decided to go and leave kano andy nosuke
to fight against his blood demon art
crystalline divine child which are just
smaller clones of himself pretty much
however though as the upper rank 2 opens
the door to leave doma's face begins to
melt he fell to the floor with one of
his arms snapping off and his crystal
children beginning to crack and
disintegrate confused he wonders what's
happening and inosuke asks if it's a
trap but kano having been informed prior
to the battle of shinobi's true plan to
kill doma tells him that it isn't and
that the demon is being melted by the
poison shinobu had in her body when he
had consumed her she tells inosuke to
aim for his neck to finish him off and
in a panic doma plays his final and most
powerful card the intensely beautiful
blood demon art rime water lily
bottastiva doma's ice body stevis statue
slams down its hand on the floor of the
room creating a small earthquake that
sends inosuke and kano up into the ear
khano notes that his technique lacks
precision and was clearly the demon's
last effort to protect himself with the
little energy that he had left kano then
decides to use her final form the flower
breathing final form equinential
vermilion eye to try and break through
him doma's statue grabs inosuke in one
of its hands as kano leaps towards the
upper rank hitsuna blade against his
neck she is unable to cut it because she
got frozen somanosuke on the spot comes
up with a brand new technique and uses
the beast breathing sudden throwing
strike to hurl his blades at carno to
give it the extra strength to cut doma's
neck they succeeded in beheading the
upper rank 2 and his statue began to
disintegrate along with his body
the next death that comes up in all
honesty is more or less 3ds these deaths
all happen in like such a mental and
brutal way throughout an extremely
extensive and for fight so if you guys
do want more context around what exactly
happens in between moments then i do
recommend you watch my entire infinity
castle arc video explained as it will
give you much much more of an
understanding as to really how intense
this part of the story truly is
i've decided to place the upper rank 1
kokushibo genya shinozugawa and muchiro
tokito into one section as two of them
are fatally wounded in the same attack
and then pass away within seconds of
each other along with the final and
third death coming moments after
anyways back to it so during an intense
moment of the battle where all the demon
slayers are attacking kokushibo the
upper rank retaliates and attempts to
cut them all down at the same time using
his moon breathing 14th form catastrophe
10-man crescent moon but they managed to
dodge these swings and close the gap
gome distracts kokoshibo's attention by
flicking a prayer bead allowing sanemi
to approach with a wind-breathing first
form dust whirlwind cutter stunning the
demon and allowing gourmet to rip his
right arm off with his flail kokoshibo
notices the approaching mystira and
attacks him managing to sever the
demon's leg but not before being impaled
in the stomach with his insurance sword
after having acen the hair and blade
kenya emerges from the shadows now fully
transformed into a demon and fires at
kokushibo and despite him deflecting the
bullets off they all still went back to
his body as if they had sentient and
punctured through his skin the bullets
then transformed into a large wooden
tree constricting him to the ground and
protecting maturo from his attacks after
a short flashback kokushiba roars at the
absolute top of his lungs in anger and
frustration and as he roars dozens of
chaotic slashers released from his body
cutting matura's lower half of his body
clean off guaranteeing his death along
with cutting genya in half vertically
genya though still has enough strength
to defend everyone somehow with muchuro
also wanting to protect sanemi and
kiyome from death against kokushibo
maturi tells himself to unleash a
technique or do something in order to
help save sanemi and gyomay then
suddenly by gripping his maturing swords
with all the force that he has left the
entire blade turns a bright red burning
the flesh and organs where he had
stabbed kokushibo kenya also realizes
that his flesh bullets are still within
kokushibo's body and with him wanting to
protect everyone from certain death
unleashes his blood demon art blood
roots with another flesh tree rooting
out of the upper rank's back gummy
swings his axe upwards to cut
kokushiba's necks but he blocks it with
his flesh sword however cinema swings
his blade at kyomi's flail in order to
give it more momentum but little did he
know that due to both hymen and him
awakening the demon slayer marks and
clamming their swords together their
maturing weapons turned bright red as
well
because of this they are capable of
bypassing the upper rank's durability
and regeneration thus kukushibo has been
beheaded however while stuck in his
thoughts he expresses that the mere
thought of losing makes him seethe with
anger and because of this he suddenly
stops bleeding and starts to regenerate
his own head similar but far quicker
than a kaza tsunemi shouts out that he
will hack and slash kokushibo until he
is nothing but ash and unleashes the
wind-breathing eighth form primary gale
slash while gyome utilizes the
stone-breathing fifth form arcs of
justice in order to free himself from
the barrage of attacks kokoshibo chops
off matura's remaining arm the last of
his limbs and as he fell from his sword
all life left and the young muchuro
tokito had vanished still attacking
tsunemi sees that the upper rank's head
had fully regrown and panics as all the
effort they had done to behead him was a
complete waste however before they
commence a new fight the upper ranks
he's his own reflection off of sanemi's
sword the moment kokushibo sees his
reflection a vague memory of yoruichi
telling kokoshibo's dream was to be the
strongest samurai in the nation with
himself wanting to be the second behind
his elder brother
as kukushibo questions himself in this
horrord form the spot where mature
stabbed him with his bright red blade
begins to burn to ash spreading
throughout his body
sunimi and gomez continue to maul
kokoshibo's body in order to stop it
from regenerating while the upper rank
tries to unleash a blood demon art but
can't due to him losing an abnormal
amount of blood but knows that he can
still regenerate fast enough to survive
with that being said yurawichi is still
heart-wrenched from seeing his brother
as a demon and kokoshibo can't
regenerate anymore and finds his body
finally starting to give up when muchiro
had stuck his sword as his final moments
pass kokoshibo questions and blames his
own existence finally asking his little
brother why
why was he even born in the first place
before completely disintegrating
as the battle finished kenya wakeley
asks out if his brother is okay and for
his respects and wishes guyome lays
enemies unconscious but alive body in
front of genya proving to him that he is
right
guillerme points out to mature's
quadruple mutilated body saying that
without both his and guinea's help they
wouldn't have had no chance at even be
hitting the upper rank with him shedding
tears gummy closes muchero's eyes and
vows to complete their mission to defeat
muzan
sinemi shouts at his brother to not die
and cause god to not kill his only
sibling left with him screaming at the
top of his lungs crying as his brother
finally fades away
once a kaza doma and kokushibo have
successfully been eliminated it is
revealed that muzan has revived himself
and evolved his body into a new form
after swiftly dealing with the demon
slayer squads sent after him literally
knocking off like a hundred or demon
slayers muzon holds up the detached head
of tamiyo as he stares her down he
declares that the drug was a failure
tamiya curses moves on to hell only for
him to declare that he will not be
defeated as hundreds of humans have said
the same thing as her in tamil's last
moments she pleads for muzan to give her
family back but instead he tells her to
return to the side of the family she
killed crushing her skull afterward
killing her in that final moment
later during the beginning of tanjuro
and giu's fight with muzan the letter
reveals that nakime has successfully
defeated both obanai and mitsuri by
crushing them both to death using the
rooms of her castle however he is taken
by surprise when a supposedly dead duo
launches a surprise attack on him still
very much alive muzan angrily asks
nikimei what she's doing but to no
answer
muzan is shocked upon learning that
yushiro has completely taken control
over nikaime's vision and with it the
infinity castle which he begins to use
against the demon king as revenge for
his killing of tamiyo muzan immediately
begins countering yushiro using his own
mental powers in order to take back his
final upper rank which kicks off a
fierce battle of wills between the two
demons and just as muzan appears to have
taken the upper hand obernai and giyu
launch an attack on the demon lord he
has no choice because of this but to
counter which causes his hold on the
keymay to slip as he tried to defend
himself and warded his shares off with
his own attacks soon realising that he
cannot take nakime back and fight with
the demon slayers at the same time
mozart uses his power to kill his final
upper rank by crushing her head as we
finally come to the end of the infinity
castle arc the entire fortress explodes
upon the death of nakaime with every
demon slayer that still remained somehow
making it to the surface escaping the
crumbling dimension in order to finally
fight muzan out in the open under the
open moon
so for these final four deaths that
happened throughout the story i'm going
to significantly shorten a huge portion
of this last battle against muzan this
is mainly due to the fact that like the
fight against kokushibo so many things
happen throughout this period of time
that results in the death of four people
so it would be very confusing if i was
constantly to repeat the same things
over and over again so more or less i
will state what happens throughout this
battle that results in the deaths of
these people like the wounds that they
take and then finally the moments that
they pass on afterwards so let's get to
it already part way through the sunrise
countdown arc while tanger heavily
afflicted by the poison and muzan's
blood he comes closer to death and the
remaining hashera gets slashed and cut
by muzan's attacks matsuri gets the
worst of muzan's barrage and just as she
was about to get impaled by one of
muzan's armed tentacles a sudden impact
destroys the tentacle saving matsuri her
saviour turns out to be gourmet coming
to everyone's surprise especially the
demon kings cinema appears behind their
demon lord and slices them vertically as
muzan regenerates the winter shira
throws multiple glasses of oil at the
demon lord in which the latter whips all
into little shards which spills liquid
all over him sunimi soon lights a match
and tosses it at the demon lighting him
entirely on fire angered muzan's attacks
keep getting fiercer adding more
pressure onto the hashera gurme even
points out that due to him not being
able to access this so-called
transparent world it is a gamble to be
able to dodge the demon king's attacks
with little to no injuries matsuri
however is getting the worst of the
hashera's damage only being able to
dodge purely on instinct and luck alone
this deeply impacts her resolve on being
able to help her fellow shera defeat
muzan she quickly plans on trying to get
behind the letter and twist his arms
back behind his back in order to stall
for time and help the others gain some
hits on the demon lord even if she
sacrifices her life in doing so muzan
attacks her and the attack ruptures
multiple tissues of flesh and skin off
her left side including her arm abdomen
and cheek subsequently confirming her
demise with the other hashera pressing
on muzan kabatsuji obernai carries
matsuri to a fellow demon slayer and
orders them to find yushiro matsuri
however still tries to get up and
convince obanai unlessina continues to
fight saying that she won't hold back at
all this time and won't be a burden to
anyone obery quickly rejects her while
telling her that she has done enough to
help the demons air corps against the
demon race while obani quickly sprints
back into the battlefield mutsuri bursts
into tears and begs obernai to not die
and neither should anyone else as
matsuri balls obernai accepts to himself
that he must die defeating muzan to
cleanse his own blood in order to
reincarnate as an innocent being with a
reincarnation of matsuri by his side the
bandages then fall off his face
revealing serpent-like scars spreading
across his entire face their battle
again moved forward with the demon
slayers slowly taking more and more
damage over time and as oberney was
commenting to himself about his red
blade sunemi yells to alert the former
of one of muzan's tentacles coming
straight towards him geyu tries to save
overnight from muzan's attacks but was
too late however obanai is somehow
straight up in the air dodging muzan's
attacks the demon lord whips one of his
armed tentacles at the serban ashira but
he somehow dodges it again adding to
muzan's confusion his arm that attacked
overnight gets cut clean off without him
seeing the actual cause suddenly the
same cut happens again with him
realising that only a blade with ridges
could cut like that the demon king
suddenly realizes that they are here
knowing that they are invisible due to
tamio's assistant's blood demon art moza
lashes whips at what seems like thin air
but it soon appears to be zanetsu
inosuke and kano along with the
blindfolds made by ushero senemy puts on
one of yashira's blindfolds and when he
does he sees inosuke exclaiming to the
others that he also wants to have his
blades to be bright red and uses his
wind breathing seventh form gale sudden
gusts on muzan as both gyome and higuro
begin to be able to see into the
transparent world muzan kibitsuji flails
his tendrils and armed tentacles even
crazier than before causing a huge
explosion and shaking the battlefield
with goto peeking over a wall after the
explosion he says none of the hashera or
other fellow demon slayers fighting
muzan and wonders what had just happened
he leans out even more and he sees gyome
crashed into the building he was hiding
behind with his left leg knee down
completely demolished tsunami was also
launched onto nearly the top of a nearby
building
crashed onto the bottom of another with
his right arm cut off obana and zanetsu
were also thrown onto another building
and inosuke collapsed onto the ground
with one of his natural swords broken
after this point in the battle only
really targeted it will rally the main
force and trying to hold off muzan until
dawn as tanjura tries to hold muzan down
as much as possible until dawn arrives
the demon king tries to slash and stab
the young boy with his arm tentacles but
his left arm gets grabbed by matsuri
kanroji shedding tears she yells at
muzan and completely rips off his arm in
that moment sacrificing both of her arms
instantly sunimi is then shown cutting
muzon's arm clean off with the
wind-breathing eighth form primary gale
slash he then pins it at another point
in the wall preventing it from
reassembling back to the letter's body
with that happening the demon's king's
face and torso split apart vertically
exposing huge jaws and teeth as he tries
to consume tangido in order to conquer
the sun
the latter forces himself to not let go
at all as it is almost dawn however
overnight goes in front of tanjido in
the neck of time and shields him from
muzan's jaws sending me shouts to
everyone to keep holding as dawn has
just arrived as dawn arrives the very
moment muzan sees the sun horror runs
through his body and he unleashes his
shockwave technique one final time
knocking everyone back except for
tanjiro whose entire left arm gets torn
off by the attack despite the chaos
that's happening tanjuno keeps holding
onto his blade as hard as he possibly
can in order to turn it bright red with
them saying kia juro's words yet again
set your heart ablaze
miraculously geyu comes to tangido's aid
and with his other remaining arm grabs a
hold of tangero's natural sword as well
with the might of both demon slayers the
blade successfully becomes bright red as
their blade becomes red muzan coughs out
blood and with the sun shining more and
more he screeches at the top of his
lungs with horror muzan then points out
that if he shrinks himself he'll burn
away instantly thus in order for him to
have a chance to survive he must protect
himself with a mass of flesh his body
expands in all directions turning
himself into a gigantic demonic infant
coming to everyone's shock the giant
infant absorbs tajiro into its body and
crawls around the building in order to
get to the shade everyone tries as hard
as they can to try and stop the giant
infant from entering the shade a dozen
or more kakushi push a tram in order to
block the infant from taking shelter
from the sun as the baby tries to topple
over the tram and smash into the kikoshi
with its right hand tsunami leaps into
the air and unleashes the wind-breathing
ninth form eat a den typhoon chopping
the infant's hand clean off just as the
infant was about to topple the bus over
a chain of iron wraps around the giant's
neck pulling it away from the tram
geu comes back in the fight and uses the
water breathing tenth form constant flux
on the demon infant but does not do
nearly as much damage as the others due
to him only having one arm left tsunami
joins back in using water breathing
fifth form cold mountain along with
obernet iguro using the serpent
breathing fourth form twin headed
serpent despite all their combined
attacks on the demon king it does not
stop the giant infant from burrowing
into the ground as guyme's chains begin
to snap from inside the giant infant
tanjunu continues to grip his maturing
sword as hard as he can making its
bright red color linger from this the
infant throws up a lot of blood from its
mouth stopping it from digging any
deeper into the ground being unable to
escape the sun in any way the demonic
infant wails and balls as it continues
to disintegrate
thus finally the demon lord muzan
kibitsuji himself is finally dead and
defeated forever
okay well i'm going to stop there for
when it comes to the death of the
originator of demons muzan kibitsuji as
that is the point that his physical form
disintegrates if you want me to cover
like muzan's death more specifically or
just like other parts of i guess
demonstrate like specific battles or
just other things throughout it then let
me know down in the comment section
below or feel free to watch my sunrise
countdown explain video as that covers
this entire battle itself pretty much as
the entire sunrise countdown arc is
pretty much this entire battle
anyway back to the final three deaths of
this story which if you haven't realized
the three deaths are those of the three
heshira who sustained the most damage
throughout this final battle
as the kikoshi who remained after the
battle run up to gyome who was gravely
wounded and line up against the wall he
tells them to go and focus on the young
ones as that is his final wish after
this guyme slips into a peaceful sleep
where he sees all of the orphans he used
to care for all waiting for him and
apologizing for not listening to him on
the night of their deaths
they tell him that they all love him and
that it is now finally time to go on the
other side of the street both gravely
injured and missing multiple limbs iguru
and matsuri lay on the ground together
as matsuri breaks down after all the
lovely things that igoro had said to her
she asks him that if they ever get
reborn and both as humans would he make
her his wife to which iguru tells her
that of course he will definitely make
her happy and protect her in their
second life the two of them pass away
not too long after this
[Music]
well that officially brings us to the
very end of all of the deaths that have
happened throughout this wonderful and
amazing story that is kametsu nyber
honestly if you guys have enjoyed this
video and want to see like all of the
deaths that happened in the past before
the story exactly started so like all of
the historic deaths i guess you could
say then let me know down in the comment
section below and i'll be sure to make a
video on those as well uh as you know
like obviously you've got yoruichi's
death there and a few of the other ones
that are extremely interesting from the
past before the story started exactly
i just wanted to make this in the
chronological kind of order so you kind
of get an idea of what happens exactly
throughout the story and who dies in the
main story from the very beginning to
the very end so i hope you did obviously
all enjoyed the video uh if you guys
didn't realize as well i also hit 50k so
i just want to thank everyone who has
been like honestly supporting me and
watching my demonstrator videos over the
last like i think two or three months
now has been pretty hectic obviously
with all the takedowns there uh i had
over the last month but honestly the
support has been unmeasurable and i
don't know what i would honestly be
doing without you guys
this literally is a dream for me and i i
really
cannot thank you guys enough for being
able to get my channel to 50 000
subscribers which is just
unbelievable and me talking about it
seems like kind of surreal because i
used to always you know like watch
youtube videos of other people talking
about like subscriber milestones or like
these big milestones and hitting them
and then hitting another milestone and
it's kind of like crazy to finally be in
this like weird position and i really
can't thank you guys enough for you know
like turning
my like hobby and my like enjoyment of
reading and watching anime into my
actual job is is
unbelievable so i really can't thank you
guys enough you know i can't thank my
family enough for being able to support
me for the first you know half a year
while i delved into kind of this career
of wanting to try youtube so like my mom
supporting me is probably the the most
amazing thing and you know shout out to
my mum because i honestly would never be
able to have gotten to this position if
it wasn't for her and you guys as well
so thank you and thank you for
everything over the last year now
because i think pretty much now it has
been a year since i've uploaded my first
like uh juju sukaizen videos so
getting 50 000 subscribers in my first
year when i thought i was going to get 5
000 is
really mind-blowing and honestly i just
i do you know like i expected 5 000 like
i just said but that was like a dream to
be able to hit 5 000 and then in the
second year i thought i would maybe be
able to hit 15 or something like that
but now it's like i'm looking at the
idea of possibly trying to hit 100 000
by the end of this year and it's just it
really blows my mind so i cannot thank
you guys enough for the support and the
love that you have been giving me but
anyway like i said if you guys have
enjoyed the video then make sure to
leave a like and also if you are new
around here and want to watch more stuff
just like this for uh other series you
know like more explained story styled
content uh in the anime world then uh
make sure you also hit that subscribe
button but anyway for now it's been your
professional degenerate dear follow and
i will see you all in a bit
bye